-Thank you very much.
Enjoy yourself.
Welcome, welcome, welcome to
"The Tonight Show," everybody.
You're here. You made it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you for tuning in at home.
I'm very excited about this.
My guest tonight is the
one-and-only Samuel L. Jackson!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Whoa!
♪♪
-Yes!
I bumped into him backstage,
and he was cursing like crazy.
-Really?
-Yeah.
Turns out he was just trying to
get Taylor Swift tickets.
Yeah, that's all. It was fine.
The stars are just like us.
Guys, it's Friday.
I'm in a great mood.
Unlike Twitter,
we made it to the weekend.
You know, and I --
[ Cheers and applause ]
Did you see this?
After more than
1,000 key employees resigned,
Twitter closed
all of their offices.
And, apparently,
due to the mass resignations,
the platform could start
breaking soon.
Even crypto was like, "Damn.
That came crashing down fast."
Right now, things are so bad,
Twitter recommends
writing your tweet on
a piece of paper
and just mailing it to
all of your followers.
Yeah, a ton of employees quit
after Elon asked them
to commit to an extremely
hardcore work environment.
Staff was like, "If I'm going to
go extremely hardcore
for an app,
I don't want Twitter money.
I want OnlyFans money."
♪♪
-Twitter.
-Last night, things got so bad,
the hashtag #RIPTwitter
started trending.
I just want to say, I died on
Twitter before it was cool.
[ Cheers and applause ]
No big deal.
♪♪
Some people say
the chaos at Twitter
could lead to a comeback
for Tumblr.
That'd be fun to
get my political news
at the same place I used to post
my Urkel fan fiction.
I think that'd be fun.
Yeah, Twitter's not
looking so great right now,
and I think some other companies
are trying to take advantage.
Check out this.
I saw this today.
-Twitter is
an absolute disaster,
a horrible company that's
terribly run in every way.
So when thinking of us,
remember, there's worse.
-I go, "Oh, now I get it. Yeah.
Now I get it."
Some news from Washington.
Tomorrow, President Biden's
granddaughter
is getting married on the
South Lawn of The White House.
That's nice. It's interesting.
To RSVP, you had to check
"yes" or "Ivanka."
Not gonna show up, no.
Biden's already emotional.
It's the first time an
80-year-old has ever said,
"Get on my lawn.
The South Lawn."
It's different getting married
when your grandfather's
president, though.
You get cards that say,
"Enjoy the panini maker,
love Kim Jong-un."
Yeah, the Biden family has
a lot to celebrate this weekend,
'cause on Sunday,
the president turns 80.
Wow.
Just to give you the sense of
how old that is, consider this.
He's 80.
Democrats don't want to
take any chances,
so there are going to be
no surprise parties.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Don't clap too loud.
He might be watching.
Hey, this is big.
Today, the Justice Department
named a special counsel
to investigate whether
former president Trump should be
charged for January 6th
or taking classified documents.
As we speak, Trump is squeezing
into a turkey costume
to trick Biden
into pardoning him.
[ As Trump ] Gobble, gobble.
Gobble, gobble.
[ Normal voice ] Switching
gears. Some big sports news.
This weekend,
the World Cup begins in Qatar.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yep. Soccer is huge
across the world.
Meanwhile,
Americans are like, "Wait.
'Ted Lasso'
is based on a real sport?"
Listen to this.
On Sunday,
Elton John is performing
his final concert in
North America,
and the entire show will air
on Disney+.
I just hope the
Disney product placement
is a little more subtle than the
last time they worked with him.
Check it out.
-♪ D-D-D-D-Do what I say ♪
-Speaking of Disney, I saw
that they just filed a patent
for a new type of
roller coaster,
and it looks pretty crazy.
Watch this.
-Walt Disney just filed a patent
for a roller coaster
that jumps the track?
Engineers say it has to move
at precise speed
every single time,
which can easily be impacted by
the weather, by humidity,
number of riders,
and many, many other elements.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh!
-The ride is called You First.
[ Rimshot ]
Don't worry -- they're going to
put some pillows
down the first few times they
try it, so it should be alright.
It's the only ride
with a sign that says,
"You must be this tall to die."
But this is nice.
Disney takes your picture
during the ride,
and a crime-scene photographer
takes it after.
"Jumps the tracks."
Meanwhile,
Six Flags was like, "Big deal.
We've been doing that
for years."
Get this -- the makers of
Scrabble have announced
that they now will accept
hundreds of new words.
-Oh!
-Check out this commercial they
just released.
-America's most beloved
board game is better than ever,
with hundreds of
new playable words, like...
And to make it even more fun,
we now accept misspelled words,
made-up words, and tater tots.
-Interesting, right?
-Wow!
Wow! Indeed.
-Also, I read that Tyson Foods
recalled 94,000 pounds
of ground beef
'cause it may contain
a hard, mirror-like substance.
They're really bending over
backwards to avoid saying,
"Fine, it's glass, okay?"
A "mirror-like substance"?
Nothing worse than eating
a 1-pound burger
and catching
a glimpse of yourself.
"Ugh! That's what I look like?"
Guys, it is the holiday season,
and the Rockefeller Center
Christmas tree is here.
If you guys haven't seen it yet,
here it is.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Wow.
-I don't want to say
anything too mean.
It looks like it could use
some encouragement
before its big lighting
later this month,
so I wrote a tiny song.
I hope you like it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪ You're 82 feet
and essentially flawless ♪
♪ But we can't help but notice
you have male pattern baldness ♪
♪ Just a week ago, we couldn't
wait for you to show up ♪
♪ But now we're
all wondering when
you'll g-g-g-g-glow up ♪
♪ Time for a glow-up,
a Midtown makeover ♪
♪ Let's get the "Queer Eye" guys
to do a t-t-t-t-takeover ♪
♪ It's time for a glow-up,
you're looking pretty poor-ah ♪
♪ So let's go get free samples
at S-S-S-S-Sephora ♪
♪ It's time for a glow-up,
you might need to go faster ♪
♪ We don't want to wait,
this isn't T-T-Ticketmaster ♪
♪ It's time for a glow-up,
I know you're not a quitter ♪
♪ At least you're doing better
than they are at T-T-T-Twitter ♪
♪ It's time for glow-up ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you.
Thank you very much.
And, finally, this is so cool.
Last night, our pal Aaron Judge
was named the American League's
Most Valuable Player.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And, of course, we wanted to do
something fun to celebrate.
Take a look.
We're at the MLB Flagship Store
here in New York City
with my pal, the
American League MVP Aaron Judge.
We're about to surprise
some baseball fans
who think they're getting
their photo taken
while pretending to pose
in a batter's box
at Yankee Stadium.
Because that's where I see you
all the time --
in the batter's box.
-[ Laughs ] Yeah.
You ready for this?
-I'm ready for you to be, yeah,
in the Yankee Stadium
all the time.
That's the only place to see --
-Let's play ball.
♪♪
[ Cheering and applause ]
-Hello. How you doing?
-This is our photographer,
Chris.
He's going to set you up.
-Okay, so, stand
in that batter's box.
I'm going to go over here.
Okay, big smiles.
And 1, 2, 3.
[ Camera shutter clicks ]
-Strike.
I think that was a strike.
-I think it was a ball.
-You do?
-Yeah.
-Yeah, but can I make the call
on this?
-I think I might do it.
[ Laughs ]
-3, 2, 1.
-Here comes the pitch.
-Str-i-i-i-ke!
Strike!
[ Camera shutter clicks ]
[ Laughter and applause ]
Let's ask Aaron Judge.
-Yeah, I thought I was
a little outside, too.
-Yo!
-Yeah.
We're on the same page here.
He's got a good eye.
-No way.
-He's got a good eye.
Yeah.
-[ Laughs ]
-Str-i-i-i-ke 3!
[ Camera shutter clicks ]
-That's clearly a ball.
Balls and strikes.
-If Aaron Judge says
that it's a ball,
then Jimmy Fallon says
it's a strike...
-What do you guys think?
Ball or strike?
[ Camera shutter clicks ]
-Uh! That was a strike.
-Ball 4.
-Strike!
-Take your base.
-Aah!
-That was a strike.
[ Camera shutter clicks ]
[ Laughter and applause ]
-But who would you --
-[Bleep]
-[ Laughs ]
-One more, you're outta here.
You're outta here.
-You're going to throw me
outta here?
-That's it.
-How can you throw me
outta here?
-Oh, that's Jimmy Fallon.
-Jimmy...
-This is Aaron Judge.
-3, 2, 1.
[ Camera shutter clicks ]
[ Laughter ]
-What?!
-Hey.
-Jimmy?!
-Yeah.
-What is going on?
-You know Aaron Judge?
-Yeah, like my body's
shaking right now.
-Yeah.
-Sure.
-Okay.
-You want to stand on the box?
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Yeah.
-Even better. Even better.
-Well...
[Indistinct]
♪♪
[ Cheering and applause ]
-Oh, my God!
-We saw 60.
-[Indistinct]
-Yes!
-Let's get in the pic, too.
-Oh, my gosh. Yeah. What?
[ Camera shutter clicks ]
♪♪
[ Cheering and applause ]
-My thanks
to Major League Baseball
and the MLB Flagship Store
and, of course, Aaron Judge!
We love you, bud. Congrats.
We have a great show.